qui
ok on y va fais toi parce que je fais je fais
ça ok nous allons si bien pour la pneumonie
mais ouais je vais juste le faire c'est
comme plus maigre un peu comme l'
efficacité
un autre jour a recommencé d'accord un gallon
aujourd'hui pour arriver au  avant je ne
crois pas que ça va pas bien d'accord je te paie à la
recherche de ton ouais comme une fille tu
sors encore non encore peut-être quelque chose que
je te ferais regarder ici ne
sois pas à l'arrière
jusqu'à
quelque chose n'est pas vérifié quand  Je vous fournis
est un puits c'est une exposition définitive c'est
un peu plat ouais nous avons besoin du
fils ellas venimeux du péché razon toujours
pitoyablement plus froid peut-être que la
température de couleur peut être modifiée pour soulever un
peu puis laissée dans un hélicoptère le
bas à gauche  à gauche regardons-le d'ici là les
gens devraient repasser olicity ok
ok nous essayons nos yeux ceci et j'ai besoin de
deux bons je vais vous dire ce que je veux
voir ok nous repartons l'obésité oh ok vous cherche
parce que vous nous avez dit ok ok  vous avez
tiré la pompe courte côtelette côtelette côtelette
descendez de ça  un peu de vie, c'est
qu'ils ont besoin de nous pour faire la vie de la ville
c'est très peu pas assez dur
inoculé ok je suppose que j'aime vers ok
et ok je viens maintenant ok d'accord
je reçois google poubelle l'ouvre c'est
là que nous allons montrer le
petit bip tu as raison père était ok mais
si je ne faisais pas proprement tout ce qui n'était pas en
ce moment juste après ce coup
disponible par personne pas cette offre
c'est là  nous sommes
sûrs
que
vous voyez leur point de vue sera kopelman bien
dollar hé nous pourrions combattre quelqu'un se battre
dans l'objectif d'être juste
il y a la grande ville oh ouais grande ville d'
accord arrête d'enregistrer